قيلونين انا بقيل دائما
كل يوم القيلوله مفيده لمعالجه الذاكره في
مرحله الطفوله المبكره وذلك وفق دراسه
بحثيه ايضا جديده الدراسه مشاهدينا التي
نشرها موقع
تاكدت ان الجمع بين القيلوله والنوم طوال
الليل يحسن استعاده الذكريات العاطفيه
مقارنه بالنوم طوال الليل وحده نتائج
الدراسه صلت الضوء على اهميه القيلوله في
دعم الذاكره والمعالجه العاطفيه لدى
الاطفال الصغار كذلك بينت دراسه ان
القيلوله في المرحله العمريه ما بين ثلاثه
الى خمس سنوات قبل المدرسه تفيد التعلم
واظهرت ايضا ان النوم مهم حقا لمعالجه
الذاكره العاطفيه
على هيك المفروض ذاكرتي العاطفيه تكون
عاليه جدا
مهم جدا بالنسبه لي
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات